une tradition dans cette émission c'est
de regarder chaque semaine les meilleurs
moments de l'émission précédente ça
s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par jean luc noël magnéto
serge
est ce que par amour vous auriez recours
à la chirurgie esthétique
ah oui
pourquoi vous êtes vous auriez pas
palmade avec lui au moins il est marié
oui c'est vrai
en la bouche pendant les seniors
alors mélangés michel michel pourrait
bouger da
non sans blague
moi je dis aux gens aimés et maintenant
pourquoi il met le pinard et mais
c'est vrai parce qu'on commence par le
pinard et puis vous allez monter des
escaliers de habré un homme une femme
des enfants et vieillards ou j'aimerais
faire plaisir vous aimerez atteindre
chose mais mettez en route qu'ont à
l'afp qu'ils appellent le coeur
c'était de descendre commencé là paris
oui nicolas et marc c'est vrai
savoir nicolas comme on le sait mais
marc
julien lepers combien de question avez
vous posé à vos candidats alors là je
dirais 400 villes n'ont n'a pas dit le
salaire 3,107
jeudi si vous avez la réponse à vous
êtes fort chez vous
je suis le frère de michael keaton
michael keaton n ya pas longtemps à nice
il est resté deux mois à nice tout le
monde l'a arrêté dans la rue a besoin je
viens de clerc julien lepers à
michèle laroque et chez dafy genre
pinochet ok
le statut de stars est un petit peu
éphémère vous dit j'en suis confiant on
verra oui j'en suis conscient reparlera
dans gi joe oui
donc c'est dans le loft que vous avez
trouvé votre module
à
fabriquer les cheveux longs ah oui oui
c'est bien mais comment ça se fait que
commencer il a pénétré
66 % des gens sont choqués par le
sadomasochisme et vous moi ce qui me
choque c'est avec avec les animaux les
enfants ça fait vendre et on peut
calculer
j'avais ventes us et je vais refuser de
faire l'amour devant les caméras ah oui
non mais ça moi aussi
je reconnais
[Applaudissements]
motion pour 46% des femmes ce sont les
yeux d'un homme qui les font rêver vous
les yeux les mains et le coût et les
fesses non non non hélas
ne l'énervé pas le wedge antilles
est
ce que vous connaissez le voilà
je n'ai rien reçu au courant de rien du
tout
il ya quand même des choses qui se font
pas
après une catastrophe atomique il ne
reste sur terre qu'un homme c'est vous
et trois femmes martine aubry
michèle alliot marie ou dominique voynet
avec laquelle
décidez vous de repeupler la planète
je pense pas que la planète ait besoin
de se repeupler
si vous êtes si le fils d'alain delon
est-ce que vous préféreriez être reconnu
par lui ou non
il faudrait d'abord que je sache qui est
alain delon
la bombe arrive dans cinq minutes que
faites vous je la retarde
et
alors vous vous faites pas pour elle
veut me parler à moi non mais vous
pouvez le faire par affection pour elle
mais j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour elle
ça fait une minute que j'ai de
l'affection j'ai le cher pour vous
regarder
beaucoup mais moi aussi j'aime beaucoup
je suis obligé de faire ça je
vous le trouvez bien le blanc surgit non
mais je le crains super mignon et les
traîtres a quant à elle vous fera
peut être dû comme ça
et si vous deviez faire l'amour à trois
ou préféreriez le fer avec deux hommes
ou deux femmes
s'étaient des questions quand même assez
intime je trouve
est ce que vous êtes travelo a des fois
bon des fois c'est des fois que ça
m'arrive donnée déguisée en femme oui
ah oui d'accord mais est ce que vous
allez faire l'amour et des [__]
enfin pas très souvent non
à
voir
sur moi la caméra
sur moi je voudrais me voir à l'antenne
voilà je vais juste vous dire que je
partirai quand on me le demandera
gentiment je te demanderai pas gentiment
donc je reste
est ce que tu
vas apprendre
est ce qu'elles doivent s'allonger
nathalie est ce que s'allonger mais
s'adresse pire est à venir
chez nous s'il vous plaît voilà ça fait
du bien je dois d'être des gros nichons
s'appelait ça sur le dos les genoux sur
la poitrine les genoux sur la poitrine
cette cassette
entourez-vous et nous avec vos bras
entourez vous avec vos bras inspirez
profondément respirer profondément
masser les jambes derrière la tête
ce que vous préférez dans le sexe
et bien voilà
ban à venir
manque de rigueur
ils sont obligés de rentrer tout dans
cette maison de retraite qui pâtirait
mais qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette
émission j'ai l'impression que ma veste
ag et est un [__] de froid si vous
voulez je peux mettre un autre cas si ça
vous dérange est passé à jamel c'est que
la casquette et un peu de travers
et expliquer comme je vois que tu es
habillée comme ça depuis 1964
est ce que vous voyez au père noël bien
sûr on regarde
vous êtes toujours célibataire oui
mais c'est un choix à bompas de ces
belles comme vous êtes of quoi t'as qu'à
dire bonne tant que
votre père est mort le 8 janvier 96 et
le jour des obsèques votre bureau est
évident et on dirait un épisode de
dallas oui non et c'est exactement ça
avec cliff barnes jr ewing et moi je
suis cuit bobby
avait fait de la prison et la wii
transmettre déjà et ça nous rapproche
j'en ai fait deux ans de ma vie moi quoi
non je serais même pas les semaines je
vais jeter des verts me croyais
même pas une semaine où alain tu jouais
dans son ombre
non ça luxe avait vu en prison mais ceci
n'est pas vrai la pire des illusions ça
serait d'apprendre qu'il ya quelqu'un
dans casimir
que thierry la fronde a mis une
chaussette dans son collant
ou que chirac est mêlé à la sphère des
hlm de paris que thierry la fronde la
musique
[Applaudissements]
alors vous est on avec depardieu avait
l'habitude de vous tourner avec des gens
à ces expériences et parce que vous êtes
tourné avec jean rochefort donc ces
crimes en terre la passe d'expérience et
bonbons
et juste à la raison j'ai pas osé
est-ce que vous préféreriez faire
l'amour avec une femme munie d'un sexe
d'homme ou avec un homme muni d'un sexe
de femme c'est assez des nouvelles
questions et c'est encore pire qu'avant
on a une femme et je l'en kull
astres est toujours intéressant
si votre partenaire vous propose de
faire l'amour à trois
vous préféreriez un homme ou une femme
une femme une femme que je réfléchisse
voulez je vous dis je m'étais préparé
sur des trucs comme des préservatifs
est-ce que
mais penser que sucer ses baisers
tu avais une caméra sur jean d'ormesson
est ce que vous pensez de sucer c'est
tromper je suis pas premier ministre
vous étiez une humiliation j'étais très
jeune à dîner chez un copain et j'étais
tellement gêné d'être à table et que les
parents de mon copain que je me suis mis
à caresser le chien sous la table et un
moment donné je me suis aperçu que
c'était la jambe de la mère de mon
copain
ça c'est vous voyez quand vous
vieillissez vous croyez vous caresser la
jambe
chien
attali à chaque fois vous trichez en
dames et man ça va le faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de maistre énorme ça va
mes lunettes tu me les rend rarement
bien sûr je te sens
tu voit la vie en rose avec ça oui
j'étais dans une agence de mannequins
simple et catherine harley qui avait des
tas de belle fille johanna shimkus etc
et elle m'avait envers l'oeuvre j'envoie
des coûts
j'avais toutes les semaines chez un psy
il est bien il est bien himmich nautiz
oui je ne sais pas ce qu'il fait quand
je suis plus disais je
est de promis le bal finalement oui et
quand je me réveille je mal au cul c'est
ça que tu allais
tu disais un rocco y at il une femme qu
avec qui tu aimerais coucher et il à
dire mandali parce que j'aimerais
justement enfin découvrir ce fameux
mystère et c est bon ensuite j'ai revu
rocco siffredi et alors là pas le seul
il est charmant il est donc
un jour
le plus simple comme amanda pour faire
taire la rumeur serait quand même été
les habits de faire comme celle de faire
un enfant non pour déjà trouvé la mère
vous avez déjà fait l'amour à 5 à 5
non à quatre noms à trois temps ah
oui ah oui oui 4 oui oui oui oui il y
avait des femmes non
les animaux
est ce qu'il ya des trucs que vous
refusez de fer au lit
oui vous l'avez seuls
ces trucs août à des poêles plein les
dents après
je me suis fait chier à trouver un
chapeau qui d'ailleurs way pour le
mettre sur ma tête ça fait chaud ça
transpire c'est pas pour l'enlever ah
bon parce que madame de fontenay
l'endroit un crâne légèrement des
gardiens c'est ce qu'elle a montré aussi
mais bon tu veux tu regardes ou écriture
je crois que hier tu crois que c'est des
gros seins peut-être non du tout
très bien comment on fait
g
tenez vous par la barbichette bernard
vous allez voir il nommé bernard il va
pas rire parce que c'est un tueur bernat
attention
[Musique]
est-ce que paramount et toi vous seriez
prêt à fréquenter des clubs échangistes
jeu c'est plutôt démodé je trouve un les
plus que les vieux mec de la télé
la première fois à troyes
1-4 non plus à 5 non plus non mais
attendez des gens qui font
ça connaît les chiffres impairs sait
jamais
vous dit en parlant de jacques chirac on
l'appeler trois minutes douche comprise
ben c'est pas moi qui le disaient c'est
une femme moi je vais vous dire je crois
que ça le rend sympathique chirac ça je
pense que les secouristes un bonheur
enfin johnny hallyday de la politique
thierry oui on m'a passé un petit billet
là
c'est cette personne
il a marqué passe de l'autre côté
c'est la guerre des étoiles ça c'est
quand même
y
a un truc tout le monde le sait on peut
en parler ya prescription
andrey d'ustou ce qui veut dire andré je
ne vois pas venir dit tout vous étiez
très proche d'isabelle adjani à un
moment on était collé guillon c'est une
collègue michel
pourquoi est-ce qu'on vous copie temps
thierry et
est pour toi
mais pourquoi et pourquoi
pourquoi ça vous énerve autant ça
devrait vous flatter fait d'être copiés
c'est plutôt flatteur voilà ça prouve
qu'il ya pas beaucoup d'idées dans le
paf en ce moment
donc on rencontre souvent avec de jeunes
actrices dans l'est dans les soirées
mondaines des collègues des cas oui
dans les premiers
aujourd'hui fumer quand même pétards par
jour ah ça dépend pour l'émission l'a
pas beaucoup pas beaucoup beaucoup moins
si vous préférez en vo mais mieux à ce
que vous détestez en vo ma connerie
c'est ce que je préfère moi chez vous
39% des femmes refusent la fellation et
vous
je ne voulais pas vous la posez moi et
vous vous aimez bien
comédien dans douze hommes en colère
marini
n'ont mangé de bégon oui
ce que vous préférez dans le sexe
et ça
s'est très très bien
ce que vous détestez dans le sexe odeurs
ma mère et mon fils il adore votre
mission à bosser gentil alors de ses
jantes et deux générations est ce qu'il
trouve pas qu'elle a un peu copié par
d'autres mon émission
fogiel il m'a dit de vous faire ses
amitiés avant
vous préfériez passé la nuit avec anne
sinclair
lors sinclair ou bob sinclair
lors sinclair lors sinclair pas très
gentil pour anne sinclair commun c'est
pas grave
de toute façon le problème du cyclisme
qui sait que si les coureurs ne prennent
rien les étapes du tour de france au
lieu d'arriver à 5 heures de l'après
midi elles vont arriver à 10 heures du
soir
il ya toujours du soir j c est le
journal télévisé
est ce que vous êtes vibro
c'est un mouvement non c'était téléphone
portable
est ce que vous êtes
rocco c'est pas la taille qui échangent
ah bon non mais
j'ai la trouille c'est bizarre hein ce
soir c'est pourquoi c'est pas parce que
vous avez votre émission à la elle s'est
épanouie koala à côté ça elle ne devrait
pas garder un peu copié mon émission
loïk le floch prigent et beaucoup de
révélations dans votre livre vous dites
jasper on hypocrisie il est numéro deux
derrière balader ruisseau je l'aimais je
les mets dans cet ordre
il faudrait que la crevette le bouquet
reviennent en bretagne il ya une
disparition de la crevette en bretagne
chez moi considérable je suis obligée
d'aller un peu plus loin pour la paix
chez je sois d'achat quand vous parlez
de chrono
alors je le dis pour loïc a l'air de
beaucoup s'intéresser à vous vous êtes
travesti mais pas opéré et vous dit pour
couper le téléphone l'électricité
et vous dites quand vous parlez de vous
une femme ne m'a pas autant le paquet
des sommes que moi j'ai ce vice
d'ailleurs pour lui faire le coup de la
crevette
poser mille mec toujours la même façon
plutôt qu'un mec de mille façons
indifférent minec en ville mais un art
book of mine à glaris et on n'y
est pas pareil et à l'arrivée
c'est plus sympa
vous ai vue à poil comme ça il ya pas
longtemps oui vous avez une photo de
vacances et c'est bien sûr ravi je pars
en vacances en soi pointe sur une plage
mais tout le monde le panier photo de
face si vous les avez
en amour vous êtes avec les jets
là où alors
[Musique]
ouais jojo extra
alors le dalaï lama est de passage à
paris avec le président la république
si vous le recevez la chine annuler une
commande de 80 airbus comme je suis en
cohabitation je charge le premier
ministre
voici brigitte nielsen la mer
alors après vous devenez animatrice chez
berlusconi comme amanda vie et adriana
voilà elle a un souffle a donné j'ai
l'oreille à des gens l'aiment
l'oreillette j'aurais dû j'ai joué je me
sentir sociaux
le nouveau doublé et surtout sur trois à
one c'est un trip c'est gagné sa hauteur
hockey
des jo
à l'eau
[Applaudissements]
il ya eu caspar il ya eu sylvester
stallone
m
[Musique]
génial énorme énorme
donc c'est l'interview alain delon donc
chez moi s'est lamenté damman lamentable
sédimentables ces misérables êtes vous
pour la réouverture des maisons closes
ou pour la fermeture des boîtes à
partouzes pierre arditi 40 iranien dans
la merde qui franchement là je chie pour
la réouverture des boîtes à part tout
pour garder celle que vous aimez à
est-ce que vous préféreriez l'enfermer
dans un palais où là sortiront des clubs
échangistes
je serai capable de la trimballer dans
un club échangiste si c'était le seul
moyen de la gare démissionner d'accord
pour le club échangiste il le ferait
s'il y avait pas d'autre moyen des
jeunes seulement tu vois il est d'accord
il chérit
à l'influencé qu'ils s'appellent gail
gagne mais j'ai à y
[Musique]
tu sais tu me regardes
très beau format de visage
on dit que c'est le
genre si tu penses gros cul
très aimé et gaia
je pense que là bas il va aux [__]
c'est un croate
nouveau concept sont très simples sont
très limpide et ils sont originaux ce
qui ne gâche rien et ils sont résumable
c'est vraiment un pitch on résume à
blanc en deux lignes comment ruiner la
carrière d'une chanteuse enfin c'est
toujours très clair et ça c'est
lamentable
tuer
laurent moi nous sommes des
saltimbanques oui on est des artistes
attend on va pas changer le monde c'est
quoi le risque moi je comprends pas toi
tu es vraiment pas donne
ça se passe bien toi moi ça va mais il
fait quoi en ce moment tout le monde en
parle mais d'accord
mais qui croise trop victoire non pas
trop c'est pas ses parents comme il ya
quelque chose qui me dérange dans ce
trip à auxerre je sais pas en parler
on les fait tu fais quoi alors pour les
fêtes par exemple noël ouais et je vais
probablement acheté à sa fin
va te faire [__] aurais tu le
sais pas si c'est pas moi c'est pas
fille qui est dans mon cas est rentré
dans l'accord tu as du goût comme des
boucs laurent située dans mon corps sort
tout de suite
allé faire sortir celle ci fait sentir
seul e si tu es en moi
allez allez allez doit sortir il doit
sortir il doit sortir de la vie doit
sentir
ça y est
saleh
alors vous êtes déjà venu ici vous avez
raconter votre vie la prostitution là
à mon avis vous confondez avec
votre belle mère fou vous fait des
avances faites quoi impossible ouais je
suis incapable ouais si moche que ça
vous a fait un dîner avec ses deux coups
pour être sûr qu'il ya passé des trucs à
4 quoi ça c'est rigolo gt ou après
après quoi
tout a rejoint
le plus grand moment de votre vie là mon
premier disque
j'étais quoi votre premier disque
c'est ce que ça veut dire kylie ça veut
dire [__] en ruine
vous pouvez vraiment un gros cul
jennifer lopez
s'est dit après la rencontre et la bbc
ce avec terry
c'est une boîte est changée samedi 6
mai vous aime bien jean marie messier le
patron de vivendi universal mais il se
dit c'est un c'est un homme de télé
formidable lescure mais c'est pas un
patron mélissa tout le temps tourne
partout dès qu'il a un coup dans le
cornet de chier dessus
man a pris naissance dans le combat
73% des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour
le soir au coucher
non non pas du tout bien alors oui oui
n'est pas non mais vous c'est quoi ta où
j'aime le matin le matin
aussi
65% des femmes
refusent des relations à 3
vous aussi ça vous intéresse pas non non
vous n'avez jamais essayé
comment je vais gonella je suis content
non mais des fois il ya des voyeurs
thierry thierry le renard ouais en plus
il est imité
mais n'a été remarquée à toulouse oui
oui
vous êtes sado château sado râble les
pandas personne qui serait un contente
que tout dépend des goûts de l'autre oui
docile bien est-ce que vous êtes sous
dos
ça dépend de la personne
il ira
powermeter d'or on vous remercie le
comité des odeurs qui vous remet
officiellement leur
donnèrent
oui à mon nom est tout
ce qu ensuite ingate
premier baiser qu'elle a d'abord sur la
bouche et ashkénazes à part ça très bien
avec qui le prénom
il s'appelle 10 2vic nom
cyrill
ah oui exact
je sais pas
première saudeau et fellation en même
temps j'ai la réponse à ça ils étaient
deux
dans projet x déjà bien qu'un des femmes
sur canal
allez dès samedi soir
[Applaudissements]
elle sent le tour de poitrine ça
n'arrivait d'un coup en plus jusqu'à 17
ans j'étais comme la table mais nous
voulons sur la plage
voilà fatwa
je vais t'attraper je dis ça
j'avais une petite amourette avec treize
fois oui ça commence et vachement tôt il
le vendredi soir quand j'ai quitté
l'école je prenais l'avion je vous ai
paris boston boston minneapolis est
survenu le dimanche oui il est inutile
de dire que les devoirs et les courges
et n'importe quoi c'est pas ça ça a duré
longtemps ça je me devais jouer
l'aventuré galabru t'aurais pas
redoublés non plus
peut-être qu'il se passait mais j'en
passe et j'en oublie
sur ce décor c'est parfait habitué à la
parole d'accord cela dit on peut encore
s'exprimer
je voyais à céline dion
et alors tu as d'autres questions non
mais c'est joker c'est gilles qui répond
si je dis non à ma première télé je
crois qu'on céline dion a l'air con
quand même si tu dis oui aussi
christophe de méricourt qui dit ma femme
et moi on fait souvent l'amour devant
ton émission pourrais tu lui dire que la
fellation est une chose naturelle dans
le couple j'aurais peut être une chance
grâce à toi
non c'est pas un truc naturel la
relation
contre nature
et vous avez déclaré dans france
football je refuse toutes les émissions
de télévision sauf celle de thierry
ardisson oui vous êtes la meilleure
quel péché qui vous tente le plus gênant
c'est l'avarice parce que l'avarice
c'est le peut c'est le seul péché qu'on
peut avoir même quand on est pauvre
vous feriez quoi s'il vous restait 24
heures à vivre je me ferai un petit
plateau télé ouais je vais prendre un
petit whisky voilà c'est terrible c'est
terrible alors que vous allez pas prier
dans une église dans un centre ville je
vais vous dire très franchement à 24
euros ça sert plus à rien
votre nom de famille c'est adams fait
particules
et il est coauteur avec keren ann wind à
mes débuts à la télévision mais vous
aviez une autre coiffure
mais vous aviez les cheveux plus courts
ce qui vous rend rouge de honte
d'être mal coiffée en phase de réflexion
c
est ce qui vous énerve le plus chez moi
non pourquoi non non je serais pas venu
chance et annonce même un peu oui non
mais j'ai même une certaine passion
parisien que parce que j'aime bien que
je sois toujours en noir cette plaie ça
que je pense il a démenti
annick et ça tourne idier ouais ce pays
[Musique]
tout le monde en parle alors tout le
monde en parle
j'ai annoncé à ce moment là que que le
départ du train de mulhouse mais
je sais que c'est difficile à admettre
cela mais si on se met sur sirius et
qu'on regarde un peu les choses de
combien son logis le fait et comme un
capricorne cellulaire non mais un cap et
des séismes comme celui de turquie il
n'ya pas chaque année et surtout la
cession-bail naturelles donna chaque
année alors je visite de séismes gilles
masson avec moi ça peut pas
on n'est pas du tout elle sait que tu
fais que bosser donc tu vois les gens
dans le boulot tout en même temps mais
ça ça ces conclusions idiote alors
moi je veux bien te parle comme ça c'est
quand tu t'habilles en cuir ma grande
parce que la saga
avec qui avez-vous le plus d'affinités
de ses personnages jeanne d'arc pourquoi
est ce que j'entends des voix moi aussi
mais dans mon oreillette
christophe et moi c'est son jules sommes
heureux d'annoncer que nous attendons un
bébé si tu passes message à l'antenne on
l'appellera thierry sinon on l'appellera
marc olivier
est-ce que c'est complètement sûr où il
peut y avoir encore des coups de théâtre
par rapport à votre candidature
je sais pas je pense à votre thème là
votre soleil qui était et je réfléchis
et donc votre soleil étant le premier
toute façon mais à 4 5 degrés est là en
ce moment il ya uranus qui est quand
même donc il me direz vous
[Applaudissements]
j'ai appris qu'on a des ressources bon
tout sais pas mais en plus un animal
politique
regardez pour vers ego fois il faut pas
faire comme lui mais
lui aussi n'était du 24 août
si vous étiez position très passante est
mal et non
non j'y ferai pas parce que je travaille
pas pour rire je l'embrassé non
[Applaudissements]
plus d'aisé oui beaucoup oui j'ai senti
un problème suite aux troubles et là je
suis je suis quoi tu
gagnes tu seras couette
et ensuite et ensuite elle sera cuite
ah ben voilà tu vois orlando icône il
habite en egypte au caire comme peu de
façon à landouge
s comment je vais je arriver je crois
que c'était michou
oh mon pauvre petit lob
et
maman ça veut dire quoi annie aime les
sucettes à l'anis
j'ai passé les gloss
moi je répondrai tout simplement que
c'est très très bon laisser cette année
voilà tu m'en donnes coach omnium
za d'andurain quand même moi parce que
j'étais pour le loft donc je te le dis
d'autant plus avant longtemps le chan
déjà à oui oui puisque j'ai comme la
chanson de ferrer je dis j'aime bien ma
soir pour voir passer les cons donc là
je les avais ce moment comme ce soir
trois ans dans un vaisseau spatial
préféré partir avec laure saint clair
qu'il va nous rejoindre tout à perdre et
à anne sinclair ou bob sinclair
leur sinclair alors 5 l arrêter le porno
en même temps je vous le dis bonjour en
scrabble
à qui empruntent auriez vous le plus
volontiers son cerveau pour une greffe
me dites pas loana non non j'ai le
cerveau
couloir
ce
que vous haïssez dans la chanson
le côté
il faut qu on m'a dit vous êtes un vieux
vrai q
vous attendiez ce sens il viendra un
jour oui vous lancez un appel parce que
c'est comme ça vers la mariée larusso 1
c'est peut-être meilleurs trucs que vous
alliez
vous laisser partir du boulot sourit
il est avec lara fabian
le de masse turbo
pardon masturbe
l'euro vous trouvé ça très bien mais
auxerre est amusant on va essayer de s'y
retrouver c'est un jeu faut prendre ça
comme un jeu harry d'accord ouais 3
euros 3 euros c'est la prochaine défaite
de l'olympique de marseille
alors quand vous avez été nommé ministre
en 97 vous êtes fait une grosse gaffe
énorme vous en souvenez de ça et oui
alors là ce qui est génial c'est
qu'elles sont halal chirac quand tu fais
sa gaffe chirac lui du bon jean fred
août
et vous avez fait une connerie 1 c'est
pas grave moi j'en ai fait noter
regardez je suis encore là
si vous étiez un terroriste
jésus-christ
est ce que vous préférez une femme qui
baissent bien mais qui était infidèle
ou une femme qui pèse mal mais qui est
fidèle
je sais pas j'ai la chance d'avoir les
deux
que je veux dire les 2 c
caressée par quelqu'un qui vous répugne
ou battu par quelqu'un qui vous aime
c'est les questionnaires c'est vous qui
les fait
quand on est dans un lit à poil et
qu'une grossesse toute la journée bon
ben non on peut ban devait enfin ça peut
arriver c'est de se dire mais qu'est ce
qui se passe là bas alors après
l'attaqué qu'elle devienne du
ce qu'il arrive qu on s'abandonne est
con et j'accuse vraiment là aussi j'ai
entendu parler de certaines histoires
mais je tairai soit le jeu
j'ai
un peu de
soi c'est pas si mal
an et demi c'est vous qui me posais une
question les rôles sont renversés qui tu
baises qu'est-ce que tu prends
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuelle
c'est entendu
mais oui
mais
mais bien que
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
mais tu serais préfère un mot à devenir
son esclave sexuelle
serge lama as-tu trompeta femmes
c'est ta dernière chance serge lama
jugement dernier
j'ai envie vers tout paris bruisse de
vos exploits on dit que vous êtes un
super coup est ce que c'est vrai
je trouve profondément vexant ce que
vous dites d'évoquer mes supers coups
simplement d'en parler
j'ai envie de vous est peu à peu devenu
indispensable on fait comment sans vous
on peut coûter un moment donné où je
pense qu'il faut partir du principe que
si je n'étais pas là personne ne
pourrait me remplacer je crois
oh
m
hu
une chance inouïe
dernière question est chose que
préférez-vous dans le sexe
ben
là je sais pas si j'ai préférence pour
cette keynote j'ai tiré tout simplement
faux nez
écoutez là j'ai un petit un petit truc
dans le 11e
et puis on montre un petit peu les
étages tu serais souffle et tu prendre
un pot et je te prendrai la bouche
mission maintien
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas des plus
faciles parce que moi la personne je
parle pour moi parlons d autres lofteurs
le matin je me lève lundi m6 mardi m6
mercredi
la gaule
oui je suis mieux c'est que celle je me
branle le 6 mai
dans dix ans vous voyez caser avec trois
enfants j'aimerais ah bon
si j'ai une petite fille j'appelle kenza
si gentil garçon j'appelle kevin et si
j'ai une petite fille j'appellerai aziz
diop
devant un hommage aux victimes des
attentats du 11 septembre un hommage on
mérite énorme pour eux
si c'est pas franchement
pas compte ils sont dans la merde sont
terrorisés que le fait que face à perez
si j'avais su ça avant
c'est le grand retour de cannes et au ce
soir à tout le monde en parle c'est la
maison ah bah vous êtes à la maison ici
ça faisait longtemps bah oui on va
échanger des plantes
bas tout est petit accident à la maison
petite blessure il ya tout ce qu'il faut
au servettien stérile en ce moment je
suis malade je n'ai plus eu la plus
petite oui bah oui
maintenant il est temps de vérifier le
drop des chiens
le coût
des niches à
65% des femmes refusent des relations à
trois et vous pour le moment
et si c'est à 3 vous prenez un garçon ou
une fille ne l'a plus complètement je
dis plus rien c'est pas le genre parce
que vous savez principe du joker si vous
répondez pas ses collègues qui répondent
et puis à les enchères donc on va
maintenant passer aux enchères
bah bravo merci pour lui en tous les cas
[Musique]
c'est donc une importance ces sondages
c'est pas un système qu'il faut
raisonner il faut voir là le troisième
homme il a déjà beaucoup troisième homme
qui ont démarré à 3 4% non moi je crois
qu'il ya un vrai discours il ya un lien
de vraies alternatives yahia
tu me dis si j'en fait drôle
qui me choisiriez pourrait écrire les
paroles de la marseillaise
je pas l'air écrire mais c'est un chant
guerrier parce que qu'un sang impur
abreuve nos sillons dit qu'il faut
changer les paroles par mois patrick
peut descendre la poubelle tu n'écoutes
vous savez comment on fait
voilà et c'est une belle leçon pour tous
ceux qui ne veulent pas le faire voilà
bien alors vous êtes le dernier
président de l'urss
ne marche pas
son apparaît et disparaît alors ça va
pas du tout il faut qu'il faut qu'il
entende
c'est pas une grève au moins
vous voulez être président de ce pays
moi j'ai un peu préparé l'émission
aujourd'hui et donc j'ai une question à
poser comme je suis j'ai un prénom j'ai
prénom russe donc j'ai une question à
vous poser
manoubia patcher la vaste vaspart hausse
qui est ce que je peux vous faire
réviser à la rue sparrow ce qui est
grave
et
as tu déjà trompé ton compagnon
dans la tête et jamais
tu enfermé et tes camarades dans les
cabinets de l'école
non mais je me suis fait je me suis fait
prendre avec un camarade dans les cas
belle victoire
youssef
qu'avez-vous de plus sexy en vous je
dois faire une démonstration
[Rires]
des gouttes dans le sexe
[Musique]
c'est qu'il veut tout savoir sur eux
d'abord il a gravi plus haut
est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé les
[__]
m'avait appelé non
les habitants s d
vous savez faire salon
est ce que vous croyez que les drogues
douces amène inexorablement aux drogues
dures
non mais je me demande si ça détruit pas
quelques neurones quand même attention
vous voyez cette
vous est incroyablement désirable marina
oui
non mais c'est vrai
comment faites-vous pour résister aux
sollicitations masculine je ne résiste
pas j'ai dit oui à tout
elle est belle comme tout lui j'avale
c'était
g bâle iii
quelque chose monter les séries j'ai
plus les paroles
repéré par graine de star j'ai fait un
premier single cap a été un succès faut
le dire oui on peut le dire je crois on
se dit tout il dit tout c'est laurent
boillot oui bah oui graine de star
laurent boyer d'assurance des tours
à qui allez-vous demander la fameuse
trêve de noël comme mon fils
les casses couilles un tel nom il a
maintenant le pays en deux
on aurait dit
attendre du monde oui jacques martin oui
laquelle
bah
eh bien eh bien
c'est agréable pour moi
vraiment bien aussi un
holà qu'est ce qu'elle a dit vous l'avez
bex merci michel vous l'avez vexé là le
fait que vous soyez jeune
maman bien
tout est déjà en place
emmanuelle béart merci
mais très bien si l'atlantique en
planche à voile c'est vrai ça et oui
tout seul sans assistance mais vous
n'aviez pas les moyens de prendre un
billet d'avion
ce qui m'énerve c'est à dire qu'on a le
regarde pas
attend ses seuls france l'atlantique jeu
voir les inuits immo
ya peut-être juste eu aussi une question
de physique
[Applaudissements]
démonstration
j'ai bien aimé invité un spectateur on
le fera que pendant l had je ne pensais
pas serré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui
je l'avais
alors le jeu idiot ce soir ce sont les
fléchettes philippe
attention oui
vous préférez embrasser ou faire
embrasser quand vous dites satirique
j'ai déjà entendu cette question que
vous faites c'est vous vous pensez
[__] vous faire [__] oui je
préfère embrasser parce que se faire
embrasser ça va faire très mal
si votre partenaire vous propose une
partie à trois vous préféré que ce soit
un homme ou une femme
que ça soit une femme avec un autre jeu
j'aurais trop peur de me faire embrasser
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimer écouter moi j'estime thierry que
l'amour c'est quelque chose qu'on fait
avec quelqu'un qu'on connaît depuis
longtemps quelqu'un qu'on qu'on aime je
dire on avait il faut qu'il ya besoin du
moment d'une rencontre de parler d'eux
de se connaître d'avoir quelque chose
qui
change pour un baiser le premier saut
vous préférez une femme qui baisent bien
mais keita fidèle ou une femme qui
baisent mal mais qui est fidèle franck
si c'est pas la mienne je préfère une
femme qui bossent bien qu'un fidèle
vous préféreriez que votre femme couche
avec un autre en pensant à vous ou
couche avec vous en pensant à un autre
oh ma femme je pense partir y
manger le touche
c'est quand même puis des trois mille
balles au téléthon c'est sympa j'ai
appelé j'ai fait une promesse et j'ai
rien à voir
yonhap
ce que vous préférez dans le sexe
ghoga ce que je préfère dans le sexe ah
oui joker comment comment dire ça c'est
en train de complètement dingue
le mot le plus con amour merci le plus
con je vais te dire c'est quelqu'un
on appris jeudi c'est quelqu'un qui m'a
reconnu pendant les rapports aller
à qui j'étais rentré comme si la
personne était un peu embrumé moi aussi
et c'est pendant les rapports la
personne a ouvert les yeux aux survols
me
ou pierre palmade vous préféreriez train
car les en slip de françois hollande de
françois bayroux ou de nicolas sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy c'est seul que je
connais oui
françois bayrou le matin à face sans
slip
si vous étiez en vente dans un sex shop
vous seriez quoi un truc flatteur logo
flatteur mais je dis virilement facteurs
d'accord
vous aimeriez avoir un nez
supplémentaires un oeil supplémentaires
un doigt supplémentaire ou alors quoi un
sexe bah oui évidemment territoire et
jean-michel
un sexe d'homme en plus ou un sexe de
femme ça serait pas mal de temps à 1 sec
c'est normal on a eu les deux ouais les
deux et vous moi j'ai déjà les deux
[Applaudissements]
si vous aviez quelque chose à dire aux
gens de presse aujourd'hui vous diriez
quoi vous diriez quoi voilà je leur
dirai que de laisser d'abord là c'est ma
seule tranquille' que la halle en train
de là en train de guérir d'aller mieux
de respecter sa guérison est bon surtout
d'arrêter de parler cette affaire mulder
pense qu'il y en a pas
dernier coup de soleil c'est pas marrant
les derniers coups de blues bah c'est là
maintenant parce que je sais qu'on n'ira
jamais chez fogiel quoi arrêt
au préféreriez
coucher ou là avec we demis roussos ça
commence fort carlos ou guy bedos non en
monospace calculé guy bedos et un truc
qui me plairait bien
m
foire pascal obispo larouche au la
raison
bien sûr là
c'est quoi
il est très bon
on
dirait qu
il reprend sa visite étrange est à la
fois sévère et libéraux c'est à dire
très à cheval sur les horaires et en
même temps à vous laisser vous habiller
comme vous vouliez oui c'est marrant ça
donc j'aime m'habiller vraiment dur
[Applaudissements]
un jour jobs vient demander votre main à
vos parents vous faites l'amour avec lui
vous lui fait croire que vous êtes
vierge et je me suis dit si je lui dis
que non il va être tellement d'accès
ouais je savais déjà que les hommes
étaient extrêmement chatouilleux sur
cette histoire de beat
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous croyez qu'on peut faire
l'amour cinq fois de suite
bonjour muriel je trouve rêveuse là
j'aime pas très beaucoup de chiffres
impairs donc je serais plutôt pour ses
il est tout le temps malade balladur
santé très fragile et je dirais que lui
dit vous allez voir je vais vous
préparez un petit remontant à ma façon
il lui mais je sais pas combien d'alcool
de mélanger tout et autres balladur
dirhams dont jacques nom jacques et cc
c'est la castafiore et autres
est ce qu'elle est pour la réouverture
des maisons closes ou pour la fermeture
des boîtes à par tous non vraiment je
pense que les boîte à partouze
très agréable a dit
c'est très drôles j'adore dire des mots
que je dis pas souvent peux pas te
faut tout ouvrir vers demain pense qu'il
faut ouvrir
je me rappelle qu elle même très ouvert
à borssele
amis du samedi soir
imaginez antoine que votre père se
rendent way qui rentrent en france vous
trouvé nez à nez avec lui lui dit quoi
simon bah maintenant vasif parle raconte
ce que tu sais et si raconte tout ce
qu'il sait on avis ils risquent pas
grand chose là est d'ailleurs en fait
depuis que je les balances et ils
risquent moins qu'avant parce que là ici
le m'imagine on qu'ils essayent de but
et c'est les gens qui sont au dessus de
lui ça ferait un peu tâche
alors quand berry vous a proposé claude
berri vous a proposé vous ai fait un peu
votre chose shota au début mais comment
vous savez tout ça
parce que je peux vous le faire à chaque
question mais c'est ce que je ferai à
chaque fois
alain chabat le petit pied noir exilés
rêver des toiles disney oui monique
alain chabat interview catastrophe vous
partez en vacances à l'île maurice
et rigolote et bien
alors vous aller draguer une nana super
vraiment super ça c'est vrai j'étais moi
vous la ramenez chez vous vous découvrez
que c'est un travesti vous réagissez
comme on ne savait pas arrivé mais
2 pourquoi pas mettre le peuple ok je la
refais
oui ça m'est arrivé du filet
pas de problème il faut aimer les femmes
avec des grands clitoris mots je suis
d'accord
votre fils vous annonce qu'il va se
marier 88 sa méthode
pour vous toujours situé de l'esprit oui
la jeune fille s'appelle ben laden à
munichois vas-y nicklas
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
mal [__]
quand votre grand-mère faisait offert un
livre sur l'homosexualité
c'est tout elle quelques chutes pas sur
l'homosexualité est une histoire où il y
avait
c'est quelque chose qui se passait comme
ça que je comprenais pas trop très bien
c'est ce que terme et les trois en un
mot alors effectivement
heureusement évidemment il ya une fin
difficile à fait
alors là stylophone question ils vont
peut-être descendre un garçon pour faire
la fête dave la fellation
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
qu'il est une maîtresse
si vous l'aimez
calme-toi thierry commencé à prêcher
pour sa paroisse st
oui mais mais par amour on est jeudi à
la maison oh la la
il est où ce fait les convois convoi
caillassant
mécénat
royal a même dit elle a même dit qu'elle
était prête à ce que tu es une maîtresse
mais ça je suis pas sûr que ce soit pas
que pour la télé quand on est d'accord
mais tu sais ce que dit vanessa demouy
quand on lui parle de ses seins elle dit
au bout d'un moment ça gonfle
c'est pareil qu'en son absence de ma
[__]
et pour arbitrer de blind test
accompagné par ses deux juges de touche
j'accueille
on se
du sarm
soit
tant que les téléspectateurs vous
veulent vous restez est le jouet
nouvelle plus vous parti c'est
exactement
bravo non
vous êtes gros lolos
bas pendant ce moment le gros lot je
pense qu'il faut la refaire
est ce que vous êtes trop quo
c'est-à-dire comparaison avait dit
freddy
malheureusement non
vous êtes chamallows
germe alors expliquez-moi
aux cochons il n'ya pas y'a pas un
intermédiaire ceci dit il est un
champion
préférez une femme comprend sans la
comprendre où une femme qu'on comprend
sans la prendre femme qu'on comprend
déjà c'est héroïque donc reste acheteur
en réalité
est-ce que se faire sucer c'est tromper
oh non
et alors vous dites si je le trouve au
lit avec une autre jeu l'assassinent
ouais ouais je suis un peu d'accord car
une fois je suis frais un bleu puis
je suis pas aussi jalouse koussa si vous
trouvez vos vies avec un mec là je
rentre dans l'émission
première infidélité
oui c'est vrai qu'avant justement
c'était à mes 17 ans il m'est arrivé
carrément de sortir avec 3 mais quand
même tonneau
mais je les sentais que c'était ma
dire et rossana je savais pas
heureusement donc ça va gérer ce
week-end
vous êtes intéressés olivier de
kersauson par les photos de eve angeli
dans fhm non mais elles sont sa part
atteint son but c'est bien fermé ses
cafés ses belles photos 1
vous partez avec non non non non je vais
renom non mais je te soir ça peut vous
aider en même temps
ils sont très très esthétique très
pudique
passant pas la photo est habituel que
ou même que le brasseur un jour comme ça
vous trouvez en face maintenant ce qu'on
appelait les fellaghas à l'époque et il
va dégainer vous dégainez avant lui vous
le tuez
exact
toute ma vie vous regretterez de ne pas
avoir eu la culture politique d'être un
objecteur de conscience est vrai
si vous étiez en vente dans un sex shop
vous seriez quoi en vente dans un
magazine et vous soyez quoi comme objet
d'un préservatif mais je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que c'est exactement la
même chose que l'émetteur on sait les
préservatifs ça rassure quand on en a
mais quand il y en a pas qu'est ce que
c'est bon
si vous êtes trios n'ont pas pas plus
oui c'est arrivé mais bon je suis pas là
sans moi j'suis pas trio pas
j'ai bien mec vous ayez compris que tous
vos questions à la con voulait garder
alors vous ai mis 22 millions d'euros
dans la sphère au départ vous avez perdu
mais c'est pas très grave 21 c est grave
mais henri thébault mieux quand il ya un
échec comme ça
partir en ayant perdu de l'argent je ne
sais pas plus mal parce qu'on tarde a
les mains propres au final j'avais le
sentiment de vous êtes fait avoir dans
toute cette affaire
d'habitude c'est toujours je regrette
jamais rien donc là je commence a dit de
me dire quand même je regrette un peu ce
qui s'est passé de notre côté j'aurai
certainement regretter de ne pas l'avoir
fait je trouve que il ya quand même une
en a l'impression moi j'ai l'impression
que ça arrange beaucoup de gens qui est
plus des équipes de f1 en france non pas
maintenant vous êtes une vraie femme
je sais pourquoi je dis ça laurent elisa
a perdu 7 kg 1 télé joue un peu creusé
comme ça tout va très bien sous le dit
ce n'est pas pour moi aussi je vous aime
pensez quoi du rap français en général
jesta bayard ap rap c'est comme tout il
y avait mûri en moi ouais
c'est pas ça pourtant
il a un côté caustique nous on est des
hooligans derrière qui fait bien de
prendre des pincettes parce que je peux
tu éclaté alors et c'est démesuré ton
propos parce que ça peut aller très vite
année
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas dire fièrement
ont fait un peu du gangsta rap et que
les autres font du rap normal moi je
suis pas encore là mais donc juste arabe
ça veut dire qu'on a un gangster du
gâteau ben un peu un peu s'il ya marqué
gangsters à vent râpent d'accord
vous avez remis aux plus calme c'est
parce que vous avez un disque à vendre
parce que vous êtes fait soigner
non là c'est un brin fogiel s'est passé
pas bon sur cette île ironie fogel c'est
peut-être lui qui va toi ta moko
gaffe quand même avant j'allais sur des
colts érigé tab et kool shen donc il y
avait à côté 10 millions est plus
aujourd'hui je me retrouve tout seul
donc par c'est à moi de le jeu de
l'agencé ce côté n'ayant pas plus mal
d'ailleurs pas ce qu'on entend parler
plus et puis
c'est vrai pas une brute épaisse un
petit shorty bonnes affaires les dents
en or et
dans la quatrième dimension il ya un
autre calendrier
vous choisissez le mois où l'argent est
gratuit le mois où les joints tourner
pendant 30 jours ou le mois ou en bandes
quatre semaines qu'est-ce qui fait déjà
tiré il a doublé fine toute la journée
et ouais je suis comme tout le monde
[Musique]
du quartier
je ne suis pas seule il y as derrière
moi et autour de moi en ce moment des
gens qui spontanément vous venir dire
ceux de quoi ils ont été les témoins
explique l affaire elf explique l
affaire de l'ôter est la base mais ces
textes c'est hallucinant l'histoire est
ce qu'on se rappelle quand même qu'il
n'ya que 15 % de la pollution la
population mondiale qu'un toit déjà
c'est exactement pour cela que je me
bats si t'as pas compris que c'est pour
cela que je me bats
pour faire péter cette saloperie de 2,2
mafia blues merde
non parce qu'il ya quand même un truc on
entend qu'on entend moi qui m'a dit m'a
quand même marqué puis je pense qu'à
marquer tous les français ses juges qui
démissionne et athéna parc parce que les
bagarres soir à bout quoi un sens je
voulais quand je vais voir les juges ils
sont pas beau
ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas
fais une émission il ya des hauts des
politiques ou aidés par l'argent
maintenant je leur fait peur maintenant
donc très c'est pas pour souffler qu'une
paille en regardant le cul mais bravo
a quand même tu me ferait presque un
compliment la voilà
notre père et par an du coup de léotard
vous le savez ça il y avait un léotard
qui étaient cloués à leuthard qui
étaient tous quitté l'inventeur du train
de résister trapèze volant
[Musique]
ghana quinqua pas vous fier quand il ya
eu les coups de feu c'est joey starr il
n'a pas bougé d'un millimètre
ya le muguet
dj
seth
rogen oh boy
je
enfin soit bonsoir bonsoir c'est qui le
plus menteur je passe de se passer vous
et je vous emmerde au canada
c'est moi et c'est moi
c'est passé comme ça à lille
petit à petit vous êtes devenu
parfaitement indispensable au paysage
audiovisuel français
comment ferait un ensemble où il
cherchait vraiment à [__] la paix aux
jeunes ici parce que je dois pas par
vous qui pourrait vraiment prendre ma
place parce que c'est vous surprendre
ils sont aidés
je fais des jeunes hommes et didon chez
nous et c'est l'essai trois mois tu a
progressé
donc apparemment vous soyez prêtes à
gâcher quelqu'un qui devient de tué d'un
coup de couteau dans le ventre je coule
le cadavre vous mettez les pieds du
cadavre dans du béton et vous jetez le
cadart par un pont dans la seine
d'accord d'accord je peux prendre le
même truc que vous voulez excusez là
très bon
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête
mareva galanter à vous mettre à la
drogue bat pour eux c'est faire
la charité qui suit le python ou encore
canal + l'adversaire mais bien sûr les
nouveaux cana
dia plutôt monde sylvain au canada corp
aqua reconnaissez-vous infailliblement
la bêtise je vais très bon mais je ne
sais pas quoi
je vais te répondre avec les lunettes de
soleil dans un restaurant près si la can
pour contre
attention sur la table oui mais comment
j'ai fait un best of show
à face aux blues and
the sad
alors ça
là
alors dans le film vous êtes la petite
amie de romain duris et un moment voulu
dit lâche moi la chatte
une grande tenue
c'est ça c'est pas moi qui j'ai dit ça
c'est la personne pour nous parler
moi je vois que le président de
l'assemblée nationale quatrième
personnage du pays ne bouge pas parce
qu'aucun mais toi raymond tout va aller
bien tu vas rejoindre le mouvement
baptiste
pour devenir belle fille voilà non il
peut faire les deux peut cumuler les
fonctions
tu n'auras pas des monuments tout
simplement satisfaction un homme libre
ok on a approché un coup quand je me
lève toi et bouge ton cul d'accord
tu sais que robinson crusoé sur la fin
de sa vie il avait la maladie
d'alzheimer ah bon tu sais comment ils
appelaient vendredi non l'autre jour
si vous étiez un assassin je serai un
serial buteur
mais qui tuerait des blondes à coups de
beats rocco siffredi
tu peux donner ce que tu veux qu'est ce
que je vais te donner a fléchi
oh
m
voici
et
alors votre maire thérèse fonctionnaire
au trésor public et puis lors le drame
on peut s'y intéressent et fonctionnaire
au trésor du
président c'était bien qu'elle en ait
attrapé un déjà
à l'époque je ne peux quand même pas tu
peux dire quoi pas très joli je suis
plutôt boulotte aucun succès auprès des
hommes assassinés center est ce que
c'est vrai en fin de soirée non mais
parce que des feux une petite boulette
enfin
est ce que vous êtes orlando ah oui je
suis orlando bonjour je serais plus ça
sera peut-être la fin mais je suis
orlando jeudi j'ai même dit que le jour
où il a entre tuer hélène
vous dites il ya peu de femmes parmi les
terroristes si les femmes étaient au
pouvoir les guerres c'est serait donc
vous êtes très
j'ai réalisé les grands hommes de demain
sont des femmes ouais d'alcool aussi
embrassé s'est trompé pour la femme je
crois que c'est tromper mais pour moi
non
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que se faire sucer c'est tromper
ah bah oui là
bah oui mais bon là pour le coup c'est
que je m'excuse voilà
vous savez des fois même dans des
scénarios de films que je dois faire je
je je lis puis je reviens trois pages en
arrière je sais ça me prend à peu près
trois semaines
voilà le film il est déjà fait ils ont
déjà pris un autre acte moi j'ai dit
j'ai fini dit nous aussi
oui il a été même d'où mes grands
problèmes de communication avec mon père
ah oui parler parce que
ça ça veut dire ses gaffes je vais
attendre
le pire c'est de grandir salle de vivre
seul ou de mourir seul de mourir seul
parce que je l' ai déjà vécu
et je dois dire que c'est assez dur
ouais vraiment ouais parce que de
grandir seul je les fait vivre seul je
l' ai déjà vécu mourir seul plus jamais
j'étais chauffeur militaire à l'adsl
direction de sécurité militaire là où il
y avait les écoutes
moi j'ai un souvenir magnifique d'un
plan comme ça on aurait pu faire il y
avait les mecs qui était écouté puis
avait à la télé giscard crise et il n'y
a pas d' écoute
gérard jugnot oui pendant ses vacances à
royan
têtu masturber en pensant à anet
[__] mais qu'on ne sait pas pas là
mais
sans doute oui amor amor
j'ai bénéficié de grâce j'ai bénéficié
aux almadies le certif en tôle et vous
avez eu trois mois de grâce [__] t'es
super bien au courant train
la plus ingrate on l'a déjà dit sofitel
marisa j'allais encore
la boîte de temps franchement c'est à
dire que je vous invite à 10 me sentais
que c'était moi tu pour 2
alors claire castillon faisait déjà
publié deux romans le grenier qui plaît
pas beaucoup à geneviève moi j'aime la
nuit donc j'ai beaucoup aimé jouer
beaucoup choqué parce que les très prude
geneviève des ailes à ses côtés comme ça
mais cette année on a déconné quand elle
a donné un coup dans le corner dans les
couverts on met au départ un peu diesel
longue à démarrer ça va ta vie ton
numéro
domanick le regard
les frais en france en seine et marnais
la tonnelle moi ça me donne envie de
faire un tour de vélo de richter
la montée
ouais
maintenant qu'ils appuient de chen zhen
vial est ce que
bien jouer
geneviève ya quoi sous le chapeau
à mes yeux un bisou
tandis que ce magal ace combat thierry
plus mais attention comme ça attention
alors le tue l'amour en boîte une fille
qui danse désynchronisée
une fille qui dégoulinent de sueur
une fille bourrée
tig ou rsa peut être un gars de l'amour
ça doit être la seule occasion c'est
vrai que certains élus ça prenait
alors le tue l'amour avant de conclure
ouais
c'est fait gaffe rarement fait gaffe je
prends pas la pilule je te préviens je
suis frigide
tu sais j'ai mais qu'est ce que c'est
une deuxième déjà su friggit te préviens
je suis plus là mais là au moins il ya
un challenge et où tu dis mais attends
tu essaies de tina moi on conclure c'est
un gros naze un gros qui frappe derrière
la porte en disant je suis bûcheron ça
fait une semaine à l'apport
le plus insupportable son c'était sans
doute les quatre mecs qui me disait sans
arrêt avec bones [__] est bonne non
wade n'a pas les banaliser jeu suivante
il aurait bien les escalopes je lui
mettrais bien la lunette arrière
et ce qui me fâche ok c'est pas de
copine pas de copine bac avec des
garçons des pires aux minettes que t'es
pas là ouais bah c'est chiant c'était
dur
vous mettez en doute la théorie selon
laquelle les attentats du 11 septembre
sont le fait d' ennemis extérieurs
en fait vous dit qu'il s'agirait d'une
macabre mise en scène un complot
intérieur organisé par le lobby
militaire dont nous raconte que un
boeing 757 c'est un ange à une norme
arrive devant le pentagone touche la
façade s'engouffre dans la façade au
niveau du rez-de-chaussée du premier
étage est totalement happé à l'intérieur
du bâtiment et brûle à l'intérieur on
n'a jamais trouvé le moindre morceau de
cet avion à l'exception des boîtes
noires on a exhibé avec beaucoup de
retard et puis on aurait retrouvé
d'après le pentagone un phare de l'avion
qu'on n'a jamais montré mans tandis
qu'on l'a retrouvé et riendeau donc
c'est un avion qui se serait
dématérialisée ouais mais l'avion qui a
décollé il est où c'est bien un avion
qui a décollé à un moment comme jamais
un avion qui a décollé il y avait des
passagers à l'intérieur cet avion on en
a perdu toute trace à 500 km de
washington au dessus de l'ohio ya aucune
nouvelle depuis est certainement le
gouvernement américain aurait des
révélations à faire aux familles de ses
victimes
il ya officiellement un deuxième
gouvernement parallèle en arrière du
premier et qui ne peut pas être contrôlé
par le congrès des états unis donc vous
appelez ça comme vous voulez mais ça
paraît assez loin d'une démocratie le
pouvoir a changé de mains aux états et
totalement
mais je souhaitais au feu non défriser
on aurait cru un peu plus cher
alors alors alors je les plaques et bien
comme ça et temps en temps oui alors
j'avais toujours une brosse
sa remontée comme sertic je me range est
toujours pour marcher contre avec le
vent dans le dos de cd qui avait le vent
de face c'était atroce quoi ça faisait 2
est non mais c'était la mort il avait
une brosse sur le post que tout le monde
l'appelait de la brosse et ouais h et
passe ainsi à bon
et après on fait un groupe qui s'appelle
les tigers mais vous dit c'est sa taille
des joueurs ouais je disais l'éthique on
ne savait pas les tiges à rechercher le
nom tigres avaient l'éthique c'est bien
mais en anglais donc on s'est dit aussi
appelé teachers
si vous étiez une arme à la meilleure
mon cher la seule la vraie le site est
la seule qui fasse peur le style au pays
de galles et sortir sa [__] des noms
si vous deviez avoir que la moitié d'un
homme vous prendriez le haut ou le bas
mais serait infidèle à
s qu'embrasser s'est trompé
[Musique]
c'est pas génial quand même indiqué la
mission
non la question michel rocard
l'a vu question michel rocard oui c'est
tromper
lequel a rencontré l'autre celui ci
c'est celui qui m'a rencontrée forcément
l'arrêt ils étaient près d'une
camionnette à boulogne et
quand je taperai dans mes mains tu seras
le mime marceau super énervés attention
pas sophie marceau
quoi toi ok j'ai pas fini
at il est très énervé
attention quand je classerais dans les
mains tu seras dieu
ou là
je vous ai compris
quand je taperai dans mes mains charlie
tu seras à lui
près le point le bit vécu hier
ça va
non
geoservices que
[Applaudissements]
michel peyrard au moment où ben laden
kit djalal abad il ya un cortège de
voitures il s'en va pas tout seul il
paraît que le mollah omar était parti
sur une moto mais lui il est parti avec
combien de voitures il ya deux convois
l'un de plus de plus de 200 voitures
probablement qui est partie de nuit et
un deuxième convoi qui est parti en
plein jour ouais 250 voitures il ya
plein de choses qui sont troublantes ans
et en ce qui concerne le 11 septembre
tels sont à peu près que précoce je veux
dire ce révisionnisme la l'assassinât de
kennedy au début on nous a expliqué que
c'était lee harvey oswald et puis il a
fallu quand même 10 15 ans on a fini par
savoir que lee harvey oswald il avait
sans doute tiré sur kennedy enfin que
c'était pas lui l'initiateur vous
prêcher un convaincu marilyn monroe
pendant des années on nous a dit qu'elle
s'était suicidée comment c'est vrai un
jour on a découvert que les kennedy
l'avait peut-être un peu et démissionner
tout service sont capables de tout
effectivement moi ça me rappelle à une
époque où il y avait des journaux qui
était certes des journaux pas très
fréquentables comme minutes qui disait
que françois mitterrand avait eu la
francisque sous le maréchal pétain et
l'époque le fait de dire que mitterrand
avait eu la francisque c'était considéré
comme un blasphème et puis un jour tout
le monde a bien été obligé de
reconnaître que mi temps a vu de
francisco
où vous seriez prêt à cacher quelqu'un
qu'elle vient de tuer même tuer
quelqu'un qui vient de cacher
d'ailleurs là il ya pas mal de jeunes
qui s'étaient inscrits qui voulait me
donner leur vote qu'ils m'ont qui m'ont
naturellement envoyer leur carte
d'électeur quand ils ont appris que je
n'étais pas crispé pour vous ils vont
voter blanc baisse est possible non mais
quelque part oui à son mode de jeu de
mots parce que normalement
en place
le haut
beaucoup d'entraînements karaté kick
boxing kings
vous rentrez en amérique de toute
urgence parce que votre père a été
arrêté pour fraude à l'assurance
c'est vrai effectivement mon père a
passé huit ans de prison voilà oui
j'ai perdu mon père pendant huit ans
comme les arrondissements de 69 ouais
lire au
nom
de la culture à la télé il faut un du
tout ce qu'on est encore moi je suis un
des plus cultivé et il s'agit là des
autres
as-tu enfermer des élèves de sexe
féminin dans les cabinets jamais il
était en plein air as-tu jouer au
docteur avec des copains
jamais il n'était jamais malade c'est
bien
jean louis murat as tu ne serait ce
qu'une fois
emmerder le monde par plaisir
jamais
66% des femmes sont choqués par les
pratiques sadomasochistes et vous fait
partie de ces femmes là alors je trouve
ça super bizarre oui oui je sais pas
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais moi ça
me choque avec moi aussi alors très bien
connaissent pas
bon bah tu as bien enfin c'est bien
saisir ne pas la poser la question quel
nom mais répond moi puisque personne n'a
entendu toute façon c'est vrai nom mehdi
baala dira non non non
non non non je te demande si tu en fais
partie de ces 39% ou non non tu n'en
fait pas partie non
donc après la sortie de as tears go by
vous avez beaucoup de succès vous
commencez à faire des tournées vous
commencez à faire des télés et vous
commencez aussi il faut bien dire mind
fait foule à tromper votre fiancée qui
s'appelait john dambach avec des pop
stars non
mais avant de le faire vous étiez prête
à tout arrêter pour partir vivre en
australie
mais françois ravard votre manager vous
savez ça adonne
plus belle histoire d'amour c'est là
qu'elle 0 au
tout elles ont été coupées m mais
l'histoire est la plus minable
thierry cet te regarde pas
m
on va
michel terreur et grand reporter à paris
match il a dit ici il a dit ici il a dit
quand ben laden a quitté djalal abad il
a quitté djalal abad avec 150 voitures
ah c'est pas le mollah omar qui s'en va
sur une moto 150 voitures donc à ce
moment là il ya des satellites
américains qui voient partir
ben laden et son escorte avec 150
voitures dans le désert afghan un truc
qui dit dans une émission de télévision
devant deux millions et demi trois
millions de gens un samedi soir et le
lundi matin la presse n'en parle pas est
ce que c'est un fonctionnement normal je
vous pose la question puisque vous êtes
non seulement le patron de la bible est
parfait comme ça puisque quoi l'émission
a eu lieu avec maison n'a enquêté
immédiatement oui elle a enquêté sur les
reflex inverse est-ce que vous avez
enquêté sur ce qu'a déclaré le chien
devra faire mais si vous me le demandez
je le ferai est ce que vous croyez
robert hossein que ses meilleurs à
plusieurs eh bien écoutez je suis encore
béotien mais je vous fais confiance aux
rebonds c'est la meilleure le pote de
vadim
on est sur cette terre si on a du mal à
vivre ensemble dessus mais abandonnée si
on fait pas d un certain effort même si
c'était difficile et je comprends pas ce
que les juifs ont comme on en quand même
ont quand même vécu l'horreur
et c'est l'horreur aujourd'hui aussi
pour les deux ils sont là alors je donne
un mouchoir
[Applaudissements]
parce que je trouve beau répéter que
souhaite son temps après
après la guerre la seconde guerre
mondiale et certains juifs
réagissent comme ça et je trouve que
c'est c'est ce qu'a fait mandana
merveilleusement c'est que après avoir
été opprimés pendant des années des
années il a su ouvrir je suis désolé
c'est vous qui le voyait plus
[Musique]
lou way
ça m'est apparu jamais déçu
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai vu aussi des
ah la la
allah
la la la la
le plein
est
ce que c'est
et fait sourire
raté
non c'est pas possible
ah
non c'est pas aussi
chérie tu m'as promis
est-ce que vous préféreriez avoir
année supplémentaire un oeil
supplémentaires à
index ouais quoi un sexe supplémentaires
pourquoi pourquoi pas ce que je vais
vous dire la vérité bas les masques ce
soit le jour de la distribution des
beats way malheureusement dans la file
d'attenté gt gt à la fin et donc j'ai eu
un jeu j'en ai une vraie merde quoi
mr bordelaise père corse
[Applaudissements]
oh
oui
pour le plaisir
on a le temps de temps en temps de
refaire d'un homme un enfant et
s'éblouit
ont le plaisir
merci beaucoup
hadja lahbib
je ne
christophe dugarry
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà christophe
dugarry simuler l'orgasme à où je me
souviens oui oui un magnéto
très beaux ralentis de des guerriers qui
voit pas comment on peut si c'est en
fait à aa
première fois avec un chien alors je
viens de parler envoie ça ne va pas du
tout ah bon non non non parce que c'est
un labrador je suis assez fier été très
très bon
j'ai un bon soir vous êtes journaliste
ex rédacteur en chef du journal voici
dans ma vie
les
tu es
la jolie vous êtes prêts après jeanne
d'arc vous avez essayé le comics a pas
très très bien marché vous croyez
qu'avec votre dernier film qui était un
film d'action ça va aller mieux
c'est vrai qu'à 18 ans vous étiez deux
derniers plus hauts de la pension oui
c'est vrai que j'étais plutôt très tard
c'est un puncheur thèse là dessus en mai
est-ce que par amour ou seriez prête à
vous déguiser en elton john ah oui oui
ah oui si on est certain de la chance
vous prend beaucoup sur toi
est-ce que par amour vous serez prêt s
qui se déguise en elton john
et on a vu des quantités pas son nom
là un bon soir bon je vois vous êtes
pour l'éternité larry un beauf émis un
beauf unis on peut le dire les 10 ha et
wing l'homme le plus haï de la
télévision yes yes vous vivez à 70 ans
depuis six ans et demi avec le foie d'un
homme de 35 ans et ça marche non chez
essai pour le week end c'est un x porto
rico soit pas d'accord j'ai une couche
de borce à
votre père vous emmène dans un bordel
alors il ya une très belle phrase c'est
les murs étaient tapissés de st melsheim
nts c'est la première fois que vous
voyez une fille nue et faut dire les
choses vous n'arrivez pas à bander quoi
difficile
larry est ce que vous êtes rocco ou
chamallows
donc d'un traducteur me dis que j'ai
reconnue c'est une star du porno en
france c'est vrai hu que tu chômeurs à
l'écran qui ressemble alors à kent voilà
pourquoi pas is like us ce qu'il faut
ça fait marrer ddd d'être à côté lui
parce que je viens de voir le film et je
travaillais bien le film un énorme ah
ouais je sais très bien démarré à 1 il
est là à côté de moi c est à côté je te
suis moi aussi j'ai tous très contents
mais pas tous les deux leurs auteurs
les animateurs télé avant c'était des
ratés c'est des mecs qui voulait écrire
je voulais faire de la chanson voilà
ouais moi je suis dans cette catégorie
là c'est les mecs ont voulu faire autre
chose et puis qui ont fini par faire la
télé quoi et maintenant vous dites c'est
pierce et des arrivistes oui mais qui
n'ont pas de moyens les achète non
nécessaire que dans le temps
c'est très dur de rivaliser avec un
comique par le rire en ce moment on a
arrêté de l'autre peut-être comics un
chanteur
je dois dire que personne nous marchons
les thomas barrack anouk vous étonner
c'est pas parce que je vais parler c'est
payet non mais je porte à merveille
c'est vrai que tout le monde
de la mode lui si la cl envie d'être
énervé il est énervé laissez le
tranquille un peu ferme ap tiger
est ce que est ce que les français sont
de meilleurs amants que les américains
bas dans mon cas mon mari il est mieux
que mai
deux précédents mairie
et d'autres hommes
avec qui j'ai eu des relations dans la
vie mais j'ai là vraiment et pour les
abonnés d'eric elle vient pas il est là
moi
oh
oui là
oui
à 15 ans vous êtes dans un centre de
détection autour de moi il ya des
sportifs qui sont déjà pas mal accompli
physiquement notamment des y'a bon dit
comme on dit chez nous
et j'ai pu vérifier la légende est à
côté de moi c'était bon et même un petit
noir avait un truc énorme à côté ils
avaient tous des 2000 baguette ans et
demi
tu m'aimes bien ouais beaucoup
c'est pas nous c'est la première fois
qu'on soit
voilà
c'est peut-être vous laisser
façon quand il ya deux mecs pour une
fille c'est toujours moi qui m'en vais
bon c'est tellement chez dans les petits
amours je connais pas trop encore
non non c'est de ce côté là j'étais dans
une carte avec des amis je suis je me
suis rattrapé une condition physique
mais je voyais un peu d'amour jamais
vécu l'amour jamais non c'est pas vrai
si si mais j'attends je suis super
optimiste comme ça se voit je m'habille
en noir
la dernière fois que tu es venu d'on
compte à marier mais qu'est ce qui se
passe là oui et je ne soulève marié
lambin marième enfin fabrice et comme
l'a6 nous
c'est quand il s'appelle le moment non
comme vous ou thierry
chérir
sexuellement est ce qu'il est comme tous
les tirs aient indiqué je ne vous ai pas
testé mon cher donc c'est pas ces
bouquets pas voulu en même temps un
bon qu'on avait décidé de faire une
pause sexe de dix minutes ils ont dit
non c'est vrai il ya des gens qui
gueulent voilà non pas du tout il ya des
gens qui gueulent il suggère une pause
de trois heures parfois trouverais ça
serait quand même du pont en béton donc
timide 30 rapide et puis on parle
très peu duré trois heures tu sait
attendre trois heures j'ai lémanique et
moi non
parce que vous vous posez une vraie
question un petit peu peut-être un peu
choquant mais bon les français ont envie
de savoir est ce qu'il ya vraiment des
ferrero chez l'ambassadeur
voilà c'est quoi des ferrero chocolat
énorme
question non
c'est à dire et
poivre d'arvor vous a invité dans son
émission mais votre interview a été
coupé par l'interview a été tronquée mon
interview été sabotés caviardé caviardé
et je trouve ça scandaleux
la part de ppda qui se dit être un
journaliste intègre et je reconnais ce
que je tire et ça me permet chez nous
alors c'est ça alors c'est ça c'est un
règlement de comptes à ok corral je
trouve ça personnellement lamentable et
bernard pivot n'aurait jamais fait ça
marche je tiens à lire voilà d'abord
parce qu'il est tour direct voilà et que
ça me fait pas jouable
vous avez demandé un parasol pas trop
pas de la toile
les mecs vous les préférez
ou bien
mais vrai moi j'aime comme senna porte
je me fasse également
la gueule importe
alors votre maire avait rêvé de devenir
une chanteuse avait était même pressenti
par jean nohain pour chanter un
marseille dans un radio crochet ma grand
mère n'a jamais voulu elle pensait que
c'était pas un métier respectable elle
avait peut-être récentes
et des [__]
et vous êtes ici pour le nouveau film
d'amos collec qui s'appelle bridget
c'est votre quatrième film avec lui vous
savez comment on fait montrez-lui baffie
fugue avec des hommes plus âgés manas
à quel âge parce que médiapart est celle
des partis à l'âge de 15 ans avec un
milliardaire italien de 40 ans
je me souviens pas non pas vous
c'est
votre premier grand amour c'est à 13 ans
et demi vous souvenez son prénom eddy
pas vous avez son prénom jean-marc
chemla
26 ans oh là là vous êtes trop fort
thiery
e
com
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez l'équipe wacip
[Applaudissements]
un dictateur le pèse personne
une infirmité la renault kangoo
ça
rendrait dieu
c'est très bon un microbe gérard muller
c'est vrai que la première fois vous
avez eu à l'embrasser dans le film c'est
a demandé le juge comment il fallait
faire je lui ai demandé s'il fallait
embrasser vraiment ou pas moi et baisers
cinéma je fais l'effort ça se voit dans
le film que vous l'embrassez vraiment un
seul fait quoi additionnel
est-ce que tu serais capable de chanter
une de mes chansons mois fait voir la
direction que je suis belle me dit que
je suis belle
et après c'est comment mais non c'est
pas mal fort il faut se lancer et qu'il
attendait que moi me dit que je suivais
qui n'attendait que moi
vous connaissez pas la question de
michel rocard est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper
sa dépense reçu
et plutôt rocco ou chamallows
scénarii d'être chamallows après avoir
été rocco
quand tu es devenu une star as-tu
profiter de sa notoriété pour obtenir
des avantages particuliers
et voilà on y est
on est en plein dans la rubrique
fellation groupe est allongée
tu profiter de sa notoriété pour exiger
des pratiques contre nature
pas de préciser charles et jérémy
comment tu parle à dieu
il ya prennent décidément c'est la
soirée après patricia kaas si vous
n'êtes pas de mec
kewell vous dites je préfère être seul
que mal accompagné
bien vu
en cas vous dit
où as tu fait l'amour - tu en as besoin
très bien et d'autres édiles a dit
est-ce que par amour irène vous seriez
prête à embrasser cent fois ses
chaussettes sales
oui oui
salut j'ai loupé
moi j'ai un faible pour ironie plus des
pieds patrick vas-y mois
là sachant pas beaucoup mais non pas
par amour vous accepteriez de vivre à
trois
noms non si c'est une chienne oui c'est
un chien
comparé
aux cas vous changer de sexe non eh
ouais s'il parle bien de seconde
essayons si ça ne plaît pas qu'on leur
donne
arrêter quand même
si vous étiez sûr de gagner le tour de
france en vous dopants mais sans être
pris est ce que vous le feriez
saisir gagner le tour de france on ne
dope ans après we
aura même qu'est ce que vous ne
supportez pas en vous
mais j'ai remarqué trop positives comme
gars
à chaque sortie de mauvaise vanne c'est
une mauvaise vanne qu'est ce que vous
préférez dans le cyclisme
j'ai mes pilules pour les bonnes vannes
attendre
tu as faites tout votre travail de
libération des femmes des millions de
femmes qui refusent de prendre la pilule
parce qu'elle pense que c'est pas sain
de se mettre ce petit truc chimiques
excusez moi c'est un truc ce petit truc
chimiques donc peur dans richard n'est
jamais tombée enceinte c'est bien la
preuve que ça marche
moi il ya des pères il ya des pratiques
je trouve vraiment hard et qui sont
pourtant concerne le conventionnel et
que j'ai jamais fait en 45 films et
baboo refuser la nage
c'est marrant d'ailleurs pour fuser
d'annales sauf avec des femmes et des
objets mais quoi par exemple gmt les
couleurs entre que je me rends pas
compte je ne connais pas le
quoi comme objet ce qui est une liste
précise donc je ne ressens plus jeter
des centaines de mariages je me rends
pas compte
de rebond je crois que j'en fais trop
masia vélib augmenté
bonsoir en bourse cela thierry ça a
l'air d'aller mieux que la dernière fois
qu'on sort est inconnu merci beaucoup
vous aviez été très gentil avec moi je
peux pas diffuser ça c'est normal non
mais c'était très il n'y a pas tout le
monde car il réagit comme vous merci
beaucoup
j'aimerais vous chantiez parce que c'est
vous devrez voix
cassée
bravo
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien de se faire tirer par an 10
ans
vous êtes terriblement sexy comment
faites-vous pour résister à toutes ces
sollicitations féminine toute la journée
patrick je je je me bouche les yeux je
ne regarde rien n'avance je pense qu'à
mon travail je suis là comme un petit
cheval dans la tempête je me dis surtout
ne les regardais rien voir que le
travail de travail travail labor sont de
rosine bois très craquante alors si ci
est secouée dire on va tous fermez les
yeux vous aussi karen tout le public va
fermer les yeux et patrick vous allez
dire très doucement très calmement comme
ça je vous aime comme si on était la
femme de votre vie on vous écoute je
vous hais
alors patrick tout paris bruisse de vos
exploits vous êtes champions de toutes
les disciplines celle du corps comme
celle de l'âme et en plus d'être drôle
comment vous faites je pas drôle du tout
patrick si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce
que vous marrer tous par être tous
pareils et vous c'était à refaire vous
referiez tous pareils je pense que
j'aurai ma et non quelque chose d'autre
pour voir médecin peut-être médecin tête
gynéco
c'est un on sait on s'est embrassés pour
la première fois sur un slow
[Applaudissements]
bar des sciences sociales qui sait quand
cette émission c'est incroyable c'est
franchement adresse toi
petit butin
si vous aviez envie de me poser une
question que vous n'osez pas me poser je
creuse savoir laquelle c'est est-ce que
vous avez un mec en ce moment
mais je suis pas obligée de répondre je
dis merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien les gars des versions de la
question je pense a tant fait
profondément actrice c'est à dire
j'adore être soumis et est soumis au
regard d'un directeur d'un pygmalion et
des catins qui me construit en fait face
qu'à droite et pierre
et hélène michaud
n'a pas été facile pour vous au départ
arnaud parce que vous aviez un problème
d'élocution devient un bégaiement et au
départ c'était encore un mois maintenant
bah oui mais
comme de temps en temps je parle comme
quelqu'un qui a la prostate 1 quand tu
fais pipi
[Rires]
sam fox mesdames messieurs je sais
comment on fait alors en bon produit
comment faire
vous êtes parfaite
non il faut voir la gentillesse de
mettre un verre d'eau devant sam fox
parce qu'on va lui parler de son père la
dernière fois qu'on a parlé de son père
à quelqu'un ici c'était milla jovovich
et que ça s'est très très mal terminée à
la jetée le vert donc je vais vous
parler de votre père et si vraiment ça
vous ennuie elle vous jetez le vert
voilà
ce que vous croyez qu'on peut faire
l'amour en regardant cette émission
oui
il ya beaucoup de gens qui le font je
suis sur hyères var on va se propose
qu'on fasse un petit break comme
hautaine essuie-glaces hurler qu'on
passe quelque chose
vas-y tu vas faire déborder tout le
monde doit
minutes pour ça
ça y est on y est c'est fini vous là
quand ça va aller rochette
c'est ça le service public
ça y est
non non tu y en a un autre dans les
chaînes dépêche toi jean michel
on n'attend pas les parents
année
session
vous arrive-t-il le matin de vous lever
de le bousculer et qu'il se réveille pas
comme d'habitude
oui parce que je me lève à 5h du mat
alors ça arrive croyez moi et à 5h du
mat j'ai l'habitude
vous revenez dans un film de cédric
klapisch et ce film sort le 26 juin
c'est à dire mercredi prochain vous
savez comment on fait sortir
c'est un film qui est sorti cette
semaine et qui marche déjà très bien
et alors il ya aussi dans ce film cécile
de france donc qui est excellente on
jeune lesbienne belge c'est pas facile
de faire la jeune lesbienne belge est
une fille qui couche avec un homme
ces restes bienne qui apprend à xavier
comment il faut séduire les filles alors
il lui dit tu le prends comme ça parce
que toutes les filles aiment ça un
moment qu'on lui prenne comme ça et donc
elles sont restées ça peut dégénérer
qu'est-ce que vous n'aimeriez pas
entendre venant de la bouche d'une femme
que j'ai une petite [__]
on est est ce
vous avez dix ans quand une quand lui
copine à vous fait des photos de pub
vous êtes folle de jalousie à ce
moment-là vous téléphonez à toutes les
agences artistiques et vous fait vos
débuts sur scène à 11
toutes ces informations
mais là
[Musique]
what ailleurs à notre galaxie
et les grandes oreilles
régine ce que vous préférez en vous
écoutant de mes cheveux
régine ce que vous préférez dans le sexe
après quand on rit on rit après
20 si vous riez pas c'est nous baiser
malheur
vous avez aussi une réputation de
tombeur de séducteur
torpeur
pas du tout
excusez moi mais les hommes
et en bradant la première à avoir les
mêmes j'ai déjà été avec elle on se
connaît depuis longtemps
sérieusement est-ce que vous avez un
piercing sur le sexe
c'est sur le sexe oui on the wall tonna
sous ce nom yaouba youpi magnéto serge
la bombe atomique va tomber dans cinq
minutes vous faites quoi
pour avec ses deux filles
alors donc on en vient aux guignols vous
avez dit quand même que c'était facile
de frapper un mec simple qui venait du
midi j'étais pas mondain qui connaissait
pas la terre entière vous auriez dû
aller chez régine plus souvent et on les
aime beaucoup et on n'a qu'à regarder
les yeux de monsieur alizés pour
comprendre que c'est un homme d'un fusil
a même droit est ce que monsieur
beigbeder ferait mieux de se taire
allez les bleus
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible